Alice:他们去哪了呀
Alice: Where did they go?
Lucia: 他们还在这
Lucia: They're still here.
Lucia: 还在还在房子里
Lucia: They're still in the house.
Lucia: 你指哪个去哪了
Lucia: Which one are you asking about?
Alice:女生啊女生
Alice: The girls, the girls.
Lucia: 呃雨轩在一楼啊
Lucia: Uh, Yuxuan is on the first floor.
Lucia: 可能在二楼
Lucia: Maybe on the second floor.
Katrina:  因为我没看到
Katrina: Because I didn't see her.
Alice:你坐这吗
Alice: Are you sitting here?
Lucia: 也行我其实是想找剪刀
Lucia: Yeah, I actually want to find the scissors.
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Oh no.
Lucia: 但是不知道
Lucia: But I don't know.
Alice:剪刀没有在工具那吗
Alice: Aren't the scissors with the tools?
Lucia: 好像没有
Lucia: Seems like they're not.
Lucia: 咱的剪刀总是
Lucia: Our scissors are always...
Lucia: 可能因为咱们剪刀太少了吧
Lucia: Maybe because we have too few scissors.
Alice:我就把门关上
Alice: I'll just close the door.
Alice:虫子会进去
Alice: Bugs will come in.
Alice:到这谁的衣服洗好了
Alice: Whose clothes are done washing?
Alice:露西亚
Lucia: 我真的觉得你这个耳机真的好好看
Lucia: I really think your headphones are super cute.
Alice:哈哈可爱
Alice: Haha, cute.
Alice:你要链接吗
Alice: Do you want the link?
Lucia: 哎可以可以
Lucia: Oh, sure, sure.
Alice:我回去给你找吧
Alice: I'll find it for you when I get back.
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Okay.
Alice:因为他比较早了
Alice: Because it's kind of old.
Alice:可能就10块钱
Alice: It might be just 10 bucks.
Lucia: 哎那还挺划算的
Lucia: Oh, that's quite a deal.
Alice:是的我很会买小东西
Alice: Yeah, I'm really good at finding little things.
Alice:你有特别好的朋友吗
Alice: Do you have any really close friends?
Lucia: 啊有
Lucia: Ah, yes.
Lucia: 不同阶段各有一些
Lucia: Different stages, different friends.
Lucia: 哈哈因为我在不断的变换好
Lucia: Haha, because I keep changing.
Lucia: 所以就有的时候
Lucia: So sometimes,
Lucia: 可能大家不在同一个地方
Lucia: we're not in the same place.
Katrina:  好像我教导主任了
Katrina: Sounds like my head teacher.
Alice:那你有就是如果说你最好的朋友的话
Alice: So if you think about your closest friends,
Alice:你会想到几个呢
Alice: how many come to mind?
Lucia: 嗯大概三四个
Lucia: Hmm, about three or four.
Lucia: 因为最嘛就
Lucia: Because the closest ones,
Lucia: 就可能联联系时间要比较长一点
Lucia: we tend to keep in touch for a longer time.
Lucia: 联系要紧密一点
Lucia: And more frequently.
Lucia: 我感觉吧虽然说普通的小伙伴很多
Lucia: I feel like, though I have many regular friends,
Alice:那你觉得你会比较喜欢交朋友吗
Alice: Do you think you like making friends?
Alice:还是一般
Alice: Or just so-so?
Lucia: 我觉得我会比较喜欢啊
Lucia: I think I like it more.
Lucia: 但是这个事情就比较随机
Lucia: But it's kind of random.
Lucia: 因为可能并不是所有的人跟你
Lucia: Because not everyone has
Lucia: 兴趣爱好啊或者
Lucia: the same hobbies or
Lucia: 或者话题啊或者之类的
Lucia: interests or topics.
Lucia: 或者生活习惯都特别相近
Lucia: Or similar lifestyles.
Lucia: 所以就是
Lucia: So,
Lucia: 如果说整体来说
Lucia: overall, if we can get along
Lucia: 大家还可以友好友好快乐的相处的话
Lucia: happily and be good friends,
Alice:就可以当小伙伴
Alice: Then we can be buddies.
Lucia: 然后如果说某一点上
Lucia: And if in some aspects,
Lucia: 就是大家兴趣特别相似
Lucia: we have very similar interests,
Lucia: 那可能就
Lucia: then maybe we could...
Lucia: 就是关系会更亲密之类这种
Lucia: It means the relationship will be closer, that sort of thing.
Lucia: 但这个就比较比较随机
Lucia: But this is quite random.
Lucia: 因为你在跟别人接触之前
Lucia: Because before you interact with someone,
Lucia: 你也不可能说
Lucia: you can't just say,
Lucia: 我看一眼
Lucia: I take one look
Lucia: 我就判断出来这个人就我多喜欢他呀
Lucia: and decide how much I like them.
Lucia: 或者说大家相处多融洽之类的
Lucia: Or how well we get along.
Alice:朋友确实分等级的
Alice: Friends do have different levels.
Alice:今天是谷雨
Alice: Today is Grain Rain.
Alice:春天的最后一个节气
Alice: The last solar term of spring.
Alice:谷雨
Alice: Grain Rain.
Alice:赏牡丹
Alice: Admiring peonies.
Alice:吃春菜
Alice: Eating spring vegetables.
Lucia: 修硕说一会可以吃饺子
Lucia: Shure said we can have dumplings later.
Lucia: 因为今天是一个节气
Lucia: Because today is a solar term,
Lucia: 所以遇事不决
Lucia: so when in doubt,
Lucia: 吃饺子
Lucia: eat dumplings.
Alice:我们点那种还是我们自己包啊
Alice: Are we ordering them or making them ourselves?
Lucia: 啊应该是点吧
Lucia: Ah, probably ordering.
Lucia: 点外卖吧哦
Lucia: Yeah, let's order delivery.
Alice:不过包饺子也挺快
Alice: But making dumplings is pretty quick too.
Alice:不知道是不是开酒瓶子还是啥的
Alice: Not sure if it's for opening a bottle or something.
Alice:不知道
Alice: Not sure.
Alice:固定的不晓得
Alice: No idea about that.
Alice:遇事不决
Alice: When in doubt,
Alice:可闻春风
Alice: smell the spring breeze.
Lucia: 不知道今天干什么
Lucia: Don't know what to do today.
Alice:你这第几天来着
Alice: How many days have you been here?
Alice:234 我们这第四天吧
Alice: 234, it's our fourth day, right?
Alice:是吧
Alice: Right?
Lucia: 十五号
Lucia: The fifteenth.
Lucia: 如果也算半天的话就是第四天
Lucia: If you count half a day, it's the fourth day.
Lucia: 5天
Lucia: Five days.
Alice:第四天五天
Alice: Fourth or fifth day.
Alice:15天不算六
Alice: Fifteen days don't count as six.
Alice:七八9天第四天
Alice: Seven, eight, nine days, fourth day.
Alice:噗噗噗
Alice: Haha.
Alice:我絮絮飞进去
Alice: I keep rambling.
Alice:你喜欢吃春菜吗
Alice: Do you like eating spring vegetables?
Lucia: 没吃过
Lucia: Never tried it
Alice:呃呃就是一类菜
Alice: Uh, it's a type of dish
Alice:就春天的那种新鲜的那种野菜
Alice: Like those fresh wild vegetables in spring
Alice:或者那种树上长的那种
Alice: Or the ones that grow on trees
Lucia: 鱼签算吗
Lucia: Does fish skewer count?
Alice:算
Alice: It counts
Lucia: 还好我们家可能不很经常说鱼这些
Lucia: Well, in our family, we might not talk about fish often
Alice:香椿
Alice: Chinese toon
Lucia: 啊香椿我喜欢
Lucia: Oh, I like Chinese toon
Alice:香椿炒鸡蛋
Alice: Chinese toon fried with eggs
Alice:好想去挖野菜呀
Alice: I really want to go dig wild vegetables
Lucia: 哎那我们申请一下
Lucia: Hey, let's apply for it
Lucia: 附近有没有啥地方可以去挖
Lucia: Is there any place nearby where we can go dig?
Alice:但我不太认识
Alice: But I don't really know
Lucia: 我也不太认识
Lucia: I don't really know either
Alice:我觉得挖野菜很好玩
Alice: I think digging wild vegetables is fun
Alice:现在有点晚了
Alice: It's a bit late now though
Alice:4月初清明那段可适合挖野菜
Alice: Early April around Qingming Festival is the best time to dig wild vegetables
Lucia: 他们里面开始KTV了
Lucia: They started KTV inside
Alice:嗯
Alice: Mm-hmm
Lucia: 我又好像听见他们开始KTV了
Lucia: I think I heard them start KTV again
Alice:我觉得我就很适合过这种很安静的
Alice: I think I'm really suited for a quiet life
Alice:自己有个小院子的生活
Alice: Having a little yard of my own
Lucia: 我也想自己有个小院子
Lucia: I also want a little yard
Lucia: 但是我不喜欢底下都是石子
Lucia: But I don't like it when it's all gravel
Lucia: 我要把它弄成两边花坛
Lucia: I want to make flower beds on both sides
Alice: 好想在农村有一个小院子
Lucia: 我也想哈哈
Alice:只要我想
Alice: As long as I want it
Alice:我就可以办到
Alice: I can make it happen
Lucia: 哎可是为什么你的耳机不在里面呢
Lucia: Hey, but why are your headphones not inside?
Alice:我拿出来了
Alice: I took them out
Alice:你说刚刚吗
Alice: You mean just now?
Lucia: 对哦咦
Lucia: Yeah, oh
Alice:我刚刚带着
Alice: I was wearing them just now
Alice:然后你过来我就把它去掉了
Alice: Then you came over, so I took them off
Lucia: 好困
Lucia: So sleepy
Lucia: 想睡觉了
Lucia: I want to sleep
Alice:昨天几点睡的
Alice: What time did you sleep last night?
Lucia: 挺晚的我可能两点了
Lucia: Quite late, maybe around 2 AM
Alice:嗯我也差不多快三点吧
Alice: Hmm, I also went to bed around three.
Lucia: 对我也
Lucia: Yeah, me too.
Lucia: 因为昨天晚上我刚好还有个邮件要回
Lucia: Because I had an email to reply to last night.
Lucia: 然后又在那里折腾了一会
Lucia: Then I fussed around for a while longer.
Lucia: 哦天呐
Lucia: Oh my god.
Lucia: 说到这个我还有一些东西要搞
Lucia: Speaking of which, I still have some things to deal with.
Lucia: 算了不想戴着眼镜搞
Lucia: Forget it, I don't want to do it with my glasses on.
Lucia: 等他休息的时候再录
Lucia: Let's record when he takes a break.
Alice:嗯录数据的时候可以
Alice: Yeah, we can do it when recording data.
Lucia: 他们好嗨
Lucia: They are so hyped.
Lucia: 我去看看有没有什么可以策划的活动
Lucia: I'll see if there's any event we can plan.
Lucia: 我现在想去把我的那个小桌子支起来
Lucia: I want to set up my small table now.
Alice:可以
Alice: Sure.
Lucia: 他其实是一个小的床头柜
Lucia: It's actually a small bedside table.
Lucia: 觉得可能应该没有这个高
Lucia: I think it might not be this tall.
Lucia: 估计有这么高
Lucia: Maybe about this tall.
Alice:我的快递应该都在明天吧
Alice: My packages should arrive tomorrow.
Lucia: 我希望我
Lucia: I hope my...
Lucia: 我希望我在淘宝上买那些明天能到
Lucia: I hope the stuff I bought on Taobao arrives tomorrow.
Lucia: 我本来想多在淘宝上买的
Lucia: I actually wanted to buy more on Taobao.
Lucia: 但是因为感觉有的可能就是他
Lucia: But I felt like some of them might not arrive in time.
Lucia: 他到不了
Lucia: They might not make it.
Lucia: 就是京东上能找到的
Lucia: So, I found them on JD.com.
Lucia: 我在京东上买
Lucia: I bought them on JD.com.
Lucia: 但是那种小东西就小装饰
Lucia: But small things like decorations...
Lucia: 京东上很多就没有
Lucia: JD.com doesn't have many.
Lucia: 而且或者有的话就特别贵
Lucia: And if they do, they're really expensive.
Alice:反正这几个软件就是会有优劣吧
Alice: Each platform has its pros and cons anyway.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 所以几件那个稍微大一点的东西
Lucia: So, for some slightly bigger items...
Lucia: 我在京东上买
Lucia: I bought them on JD.com.
Lucia: 因为大一点的比如说我的那个
Lucia: Like for example, my...
Lucia: 我的那个照片墙
Lucia: My photo wall.
Lucia: 我现在发现我的照片墙买的有点小
Lucia: I realized my photo wall is a bit small.
Lucia: 因为就是我本来是想买个
Lucia: I initially wanted to buy a bigger one.
Lucia: 大一点的
Lucia: A bigger one.
Lucia: 然后但是大一点的
Lucia: But then I thought, would it be too big?
Lucia: 我就想他那个就是会不会太大了
Lucia: Because I didn't measure the exact dimensions.
Lucia: 因为我其实没有量
Lucia: I didn't measure the length and width of my room.
Lucia: 我那个房子具体的长宽
Lucia: So, I just guessed.
Lucia: 我就买一个小的
Lucia: I'll just buy a small one.
Lucia: 但是小的到了之后
Lucia: But when the small one arrived,
Lucia: 我发现好像有那么一点点小
Lucia: I found it was a bit too small.
Lucia: 希望有那个渔网给它装饰一下之后
Lucia: I hope after decorating it with the fishing net,
Lucia: 能显得不那么空
Lucia: it won't look so empty.
Lucia: 因为只挂一个小的看起来还挺空的
Lucia: Because just hanging one small thing looks quite empty.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: Then,
Lucia: 我照片墙和小柜子就在京东上买的
Lucia: I bought my photo wall and small cabinet on JD.com.
Lucia: 还买了一个小夜灯
Lucia: I also bought a small night light.
Alice:嗯小夜灯不错
Alice: Hmm, a small night light sounds nice.
Alice:本来想买一个氛围灯后来发现
Alice: I originally wanted to buy an atmosphere light, but then I found out
Alice:氛围灯都是那种主播啊什么的用的
Alice: atmosphere lights are usually used by streamers and such.
Alice:就没有我想要的灯光颜色
Alice: They didn't have the color I wanted.
Lucia: 哦对我本来也是
Lucia: Oh right, I also wanted to
Lucia: 我本来不是想买个那种可以水波纹的
Lucia: buy one of those lights that can make water ripple effects.
Lucia: 那样的灯
Lucia: That kind of light.
Lucia: 然后但是那种水波纹灯
Lucia: But those water ripple lights,
Lucia: 我觉得就是
Lucia: I feel like
Lucia: 好像它效果都不是那么好看
Lucia: their effects don't look that good.
Lucia: 如果好看的话就特别贵
Lucia: If they look good, they're really expensive.
Lucia: 是的就大概得一二百那种
Lucia: Yes, they cost around one or two hundred.
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes.
Lucia: 然后我觉得
Lucia: Then I thought,
Lucia: 哎呀这个这个小灯好像不必要那么贵
Lucia: this small light doesn't need to be so expensive.
Lucia: 然后我就就换了一个小夜灯
Lucia: So I just switched to a small night light.
Lucia: 但那个夜灯因为是在京东上
Lucia: But that night light, because it was from JD.com,
Lucia: 所以没有淘宝上便宜的
Lucia: it wasn't as cheap as the ones on Taobao.
Lucia: 就小东西哎
Lucia: For small things,
Lucia: 还是在淘宝上更省
Lucia: it's still more economical to shop on Taobao.
Alice:我有几个在拼多多上买的
Alice: I bought a few things from Pinduoduo.
Alice:拼多多也很适合买那种小小的
Alice: Pinduoduo is also good for buying small items.
Alice:小的东西
Alice: Small things.
Lucia: 拼多多的话
Lucia: On Pinduoduo,
Lucia: 他他能就是比较快的送到吗
Lucia: can they deliver quickly?
Alice:不一定就跟淘宝那种差不多
Alice: Not necessarily, it's similar to Taobao.
Alice:像那种不像京东账有自己的物流
Alice: Unlike JD.com, they don't have their own logistics.
Alice:没有
Alice: They don't.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Alice:谢
Alice: Thanks.
Jake: 来来吧
Jake: Come on.
Alice:谢
Alice: Thanks.
Jake: 每天都要
Jake: Every day.
Alice:你没有用过拼多多吗
Alice: Have you never used Pinduoduo?
Jake: 我没有用过
Jake: I have never used it.
Jake: 放到放到要不就放
Jake: Put it, put it, or just put it...
Jake: 哎就放放客厅吧
Jake: Oh, just put it in the living room.
Jake: 也行放客厅放客厅放客厅
Jake: Yeah, putting it in the living room works.
Jake: 拍拍得了
Jake: Just take a picture of it.
Jake: 要不放二楼去
Jake: Or put it on the second floor.
Jake: 放二楼拆吧
Jake: Put it on the second floor and unpack it.
Jake: 位置大一点放二楼桌上拆吧
Jake: There's more space, unpack it on the table on the second floor.
Jake: 来来来认领一下吧
Jake: Come on, claim your stuff.
Lucia: 我想给你看那个小夜灯
Lucia: I want to show you this little night light.
Lucia: 他真的很可爱
Lucia: It's really cute.
Lucia: 是我特别喜欢玩的一个
Lucia: It's one of my favorite little games.
Lucia: 以前特别喜欢玩的一个小游戏
Lucia: It was one of my favorite little games to play before.
Lucia: 里面的那种
Lucia: The kind inside.
Alice:恩，我看看
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Lucia: 看有没有很可爱
Lucia: See, isn't it cute?
Lucia: 这是纪念碑谷
Lucia: This is Monument Valley.
Alice:嗯好可爱这是那个什么小人
Alice:就通关那个小人
Alice: Just pass the little guy.
Lucia: 对对对我觉得他这个设计还蛮好看的
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, I think the design is quite nice.
Lucia: 希望他到了好看不好看我就退货了
Lucia: Hopefully it looks good, if not, I'll just return it.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Alice:啥呀
Alice: What?
Alice:嗯没什么吧
Alice: Hmm, nothing much.
Jake: 谁不好意思
Jake: Who's embarrassed?
Jake: 薇薇为什么不好意思
Jake: Why is Tasha embarrassed?
Alice:微微
Alice: Tasha.
Alice:呃不晓得
Alice: Uh, I don't know.
Alice:看看我的快递
Alice: Look at my package.
Alice:明天
Alice: Tomorrow.
Jake: 你快递有单号的话你可以群里面问他
Jake: If your package has a tracking number, you can ask in the group.
Jake: 那你就在群里面干他
Jake: Then just deal with it in the group.
Lucia: battle一下对
Lucia: Battle it out, yeah.
Jake: 你们会说家乡话吗
Jake: Can you speak your hometown dialect?
Alice:会啊
Alice: Yeah.
Lucia: 但是北方话
Lucia: But it's a northern dialect.
Lucia: 其实就是普通话基础上变个调
Lucia: It's basically just a variation of Mandarin.
Jake: 变调是确实是
Jake: A variation, that’s true.
Lucia: 你们那边你挡着了
Lucia: Hey, you're blocking them over there.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Lucia: 嗯你们那边应该有
Lucia: Yeah, you guys should have it over there.
Alice:对
Alice: Right.
Alice:如果只是变调的话
Alice: If it's just about changing the tone,
Alice:我的调很准
Alice: my tone is pretty accurate.
Alice:但是如果说就是专有的一些那啥
Alice: But if it's about specific things, then...
Alice:就不带啥
Alice: I can't really...
Alice:就是我能听出来谁是
Alice: Like, I can tell who's from
Alice:呃郑州的谁不是郑州的
Alice: uh, Zhengzhou and who's not.
Alice:就是那种
Alice: Like that.
Alice:河南话不是也分区的吗
Alice: Doesn't Henan dialect have different regions too?
Lucia: 那已经很厉害了我根本
Lucia: That's already impressive. I can't even...
Alice:这个很难界定吧
Alice: It's hard to define, right?
Alice:是一个连续统
Alice: It's a continuum.
Alice:没有很极端
Alice: It's not extreme.
Jake: 那陕西会分吗
Jake: So does Shaanxi have divisions too?
Lucia: 会分但我我其实听不出来
Lucia: Yes, but I actually can't tell.
Jake: 西安和比如说汉中
Jake: Xi'an and, for example, Hanzhong?
Lucia: 对会有区别
Lucia: Yeah, there are differences.
Lucia: 像我那个
Lucia: Like, I...
Lucia: 我有我有
Lucia: I have, I have...
Lucia: 我有舍友然后他们也是陕西人
Lucia: I have roommates who are also from Shaanxi.
Lucia: 然后我给他们说就我
Lucia: And I tell them that...
Lucia: 因为我们家就是说普通话比较多
Lucia: We mostly speak Mandarin at home.
Lucia: 然后就
Lucia: So...
Lucia: 只有我姥姥姥爷他们说那个陕
Lucia: Only my grandparents speak Shaanxi dialect.
Lucia: 陕西话
Lucia: Shaanxi dialect.
Lucia: 而且他们应该是因为上年纪了
Lucia: And they probably started speaking Mandarin because of their age.
Lucia: 才开始说普通话
Lucia: So their accent didn't change.
Lucia: 所以口音改不过来
Lucia: So it's like Shaanxi Mandarin.
Lucia: 所以就是那种陕普
Lucia: Not pure Shaanxi dialect.
Lucia: 而不是纯正的陕西话
Alice:佟掌柜就是陕西的
Alice: Tong Zhanggui is from Shaanxi.
Lucia: 对所以就是就是
Lucia: Yeah, so it's like...
Lucia: 那有
Lucia: So...
Lucia: 就是我给他们说的时候
Lucia: When I tell them...
Lucia: 我舍友就说啊说你说的是西安话
Lucia: My roommates say, oh, you're speaking Xi'an dialect.
Lucia: 但是就是你让我去听
Lucia: But if you let me listen to
Lucia: 不同地区的话的话我听不出来
Lucia: different regional dialects, I can't tell the difference.
Lucia: 我觉得都一样的
Lucia: I think they're all the same.
Lucia: 也会有一点点区别吧
Lucia: There might be a little difference.
Jake: 西安和陕北会有大的差别吗
Jake: Is there a big difference between Xi'an and northern Shaanxi?
Lucia: 哦好像陕北口音会差别大一点
Lucia: Oh, it seems like the northern Shaanxi accent is a bit more different.
Lucia: 就是陕北会
Lucia: Northern Shaanxi...
Lucia: 怎么形容呢
Lucia: How do I describe it?
Lucia: 形容不出来
Lucia: I can't describe it.
Lucia: 但是对会那个差别
Lucia: But yeah, there's that difference.
Lucia: 能就是可能能听出来一点
Lucia: You might be able to tell a bit.
Alice:我的神啊
Alice: Oh my god.
Lucia: 但是其他的就听不太出来
Lucia: But other than that, you can't really tell.
Lucia: 不会觉得都一样
Lucia: They all sound the same.
Jake: 这就是我们要摆甜品的东西嗯
Jake: This is where we're going to set up the desserts, right?
Jake: 今天没太阳
Jake: No sun today.
Alice:今天应该是多云
Alice: It's supposed to be cloudy today.
Alice:昨天其实也是
Alice: Yesterday was too, actually.
Alice:我闻一下
Alice: Let me smell.
Jake: 我午饭已经买好了
Jake: I've already bought lunch.
Jake: 哇买了
Jake: Wow, I got it.
Lucia: 饺子吗
Lucia: Dumplings?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 还有那个香椿饼
Jake: And that Chinese toon pancake.
Lucia: 谁香椿饼
Lucia: Who's got the Chinese toon pancake?
Jake: 香椿饼哎
Jake: Yeah, the Chinese toon pancake.
Lucia: 可以我喜欢香椿香椿
Lucia: Nice, I like Chinese toon, Chinese toon.
Alice:坏啊我闻见了
Alice: Oh no, I can smell it.
Tasha: 香椿是什么
Tasha: What's Chinese toon?
Alice:今天是谷雨
Alice: Today is "Grain Rain".
Alice:所以要吃香椿椿菜
Alice: So, we should eat Chinese toon.
Jake: 这就是莫名其妙的多了一个环节
Jake: This just added a random step.
Jake: 我也不知道
Jake: I don't even know.
Alice:是谁这么有生活品味
Alice: Who's so into living well?
Alice:修硕吗
Alice: Is it Shure?
Alice:是今天确实应该吃香椿
Alice: Yes, today we should definitely eat Chinese toon.
Tasha: 香椿是什么
Tasha: What's Chinese toon?
Alice:香椿是一种菜
Alice: Chinese toon is a type of vegetable.
Lucia: 荠菜
Lucia: Shepherd's purse.
Lucia: 是荠菜吗
Lucia: Is it shepherd's purse?
Alice:不是荠菜
Alice: No, it's not shepherd's purse.
Jake: 荠就差不多的东西吧
Jake: Shepherd's purse is a similar thing, right?
Jake: 我也说不上
Jake: I can't really say.
Alice:荠菜是地上挖的香椿树上长的
Alice: Shepherd's purse grows in the ground, and toon leaves grow on trees.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 大白菜
Jake: Napa cabbage.
Jake: 感觉是文件
Jake: Feels like a document.
Jake: 放文件呢
Jake: For documents.
Jake: 放笔筒笔筒
Jake: For pens, pen holders.
Jake: 放文件袋
Jake: For document bags.
Alice:哈哈哈文件袋
Alice: Haha, document bags.
Jake: 文件夹
Jake: Document folders.
Tasha: 做完我就带回去放文件夹哈哈哈
Tasha: After I finish, I'll take it home and put it in a document folder, haha.
Lucia: 我可以申请瓜分一个吗带回去
Lucia: Can I apply to split one and take it home?
Tasha: 你想要瓜分哪个
Tasha: Which one do you want to split?
Lucia: 可能这个吧
Lucia: Maybe this one.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Jake: 对这能放记事本
Jake: Yeah, this can hold a notebook.
Lucia: 底下可以放点小东西
Lucia: You can put some small things underneath.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 然后上面上面可以放我买那个小夜灯
Lucia: And then on top, I can put the little night light I bought.
Lucia: 我打算把那个夜灯给他带回家去
Lucia: I'm planning to take that night light home.
Tasha: 这个怎么弄啊
Tasha: How does this work?
Jake: 这是啥呀
Jake: What is this?
Alice:应该有螺丝
Alice: There should be screws.
Alice:可以把那个钉拧上去
Alice: You can screw that nail in.
Jake: 哎哦这个确实哦
Jake: Oh, yeah, that makes sense.
Lucia: 那您那个您那个
Lucia: That one, that one.
Tasha: 那个敲螺丝刀没有给
Tasha: That screwdriver is missing.
Jake: 确实
Jake: True.
Lucia: 没事杨老板好多螺丝刀
Lucia: No worries, Jake has a lot of screwdrivers.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 放这吧就一个
Jake: Just put this one here.
Jake: 哈哈哈啊啊啊
Jake: Hahaha, ahh.
Tasha: 不是还有一个吗
Tasha: Isn't there another one?
Jake: 这里面还有两个好像
Jake: There are two more in here, I think.
Jake: 希望没有
Jake: Hopefully not.
Lucia: 这还有一个够了吗
Lucia: There's another one here, is that enough?
Jake: 不够
Jake: Not enough.
Jake: 四个
Jake: Four.
Tasha: 这不是三个吗
Tasha: Isn't this three?
Tasha: 这上面还有一个
Tasha: There's one more on top.
Jake: 对不起
Jake: I'm sorry
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Okay
Lucia: 这就是单独的吗
Lucia: Is this the solo one?
Tasha: 嗯好像是
Tasha: Yeah, I think so
Tasha: 我也不知道
Tasha: I don't know either
Jake: 今天晒不了太阳
Jake: No sunbathing today
Jake: 有点亏亏的
Jake: Kind of a bummer
Tasha: 还挺好看
Tasha: Still looks pretty good
Alice:牵手
Alice: Holding hands
Lucia: 走走走哈哈哈
Lucia: Let's go, let's go, hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈今天可以去春游
Lucia: Haha, we can go on a spring outing today
Tasha: 他们说今天不春游
Tasha: They said no outing today
Alice:今天应该就在家里蹲
Alice: We're probably just staying at home today
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 不一定非要春游
Lucia: We don't necessarily have to go on an outing
Alice:咋了微微烫的还是嘛
Alice: What's up? Is it still hot?
Tasha: 烫的吧应该
Tasha: Probably hot, I guess
Tasha: 以前烫的对
Tasha: It was hot before, right
Tasha: 已经不记得了
Tasha: I don't remember anymore
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Lucia: 哎你画了一个项链
Lucia: Hey, you drew a necklace
Alice:跟他的衣服配套的
Alice: To match his clothes
Alice:超可爱的
Alice: Super cute
Alice:小心思小妙小妙思
Alice: Little thoughts, little clever ideas
Lucia: 好多巴胺
Lucia: So much dopamine
Lucia: 女孩
Lucia: Girls
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Alright
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Alice:没事吧明显吗
Alice: It's okay, is it obvious?
Alice:啥呀哦
Alice: What? Oh
Tasha: 我还以为不是那个头发
Tasha: I thought it wasn't that hair
Alice:帮你弄一下
Alice: Let me fix it for you
Tasha: 我还以为是内衣带
Tasha: I thought it was a bra strap
Tasha: 太明显了
Tasha: Too obvious
Alice:这有什么的没事
Alice: It's no big deal
Alice:坐这吹会风吗饿吗
Alice: Wanna sit here and enjoy the breeze? Hungry?
Tasha: 现在好像还不太饿
Tasha: Not really hungry yet
Jake: 这是我22年年底在
Jake: This is what I did at the end of 2022
Tasha: 小米是吗
Tasha: With Xiaomi, right?
Lucia: 这是你那个超高级的曲子吗
Lucia: Is this your super advanced piece?
Jake:对这不是小米
Jake: Right, this isn't Xiaomi.
Jake:我也不知道是
Jake: I also don't know if it's...
Jake: 就就是
Jake: It just is...
Tasha: 小米也有
Tasha: Xiaomi has it too.
Jake: 嗯挺多的这种
Jake: Yeah, there are quite a lot of these.
Jake: 嗯那年隔离回国
Jake: That year I had to quarantine when I returned to the country.
Jake: 隔离在酒店
Jake: Quarantined in a hotel.
Tasha: 这是干嘛的
Tasha: What is this for?
Tasha: 这是不同的头吗
Tasha: Are these different heads?
Jake: 对拆电脑的
Jake: Yeah, for taking apart computers.
Jake: 当时把我麦克给拆了
Jake: Back then, I took apart my mic.
Jake: 然后拆了没装回去
Jake: Then I didn't put it back together.
Jake: 哈哈哈最后变成个台式机
Jake: Haha, it ended up becoming a desktop.
Jake: 啊哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake: 惊慌散了
Jake: The panic was over.
Jake: 你知道散装了
Jake: You know, it was in pieces.
Jake: 哦行吧
Jake: Oh well.
Alice:哈哈哈
Lucia: 散装但依然能用
Lucia: It's in pieces but still works.
Jake: 散装能用
Jake: It works in pieces.
Tasha: 哇这这怎么不算一种赛博朋克呢
Tasha: Wow, isn't this kind of cyberpunk?
Lucia: 哇行吧
Lucia: Wow, okay.
Lucia: 我修我修过
Lucia: I've repaired, I've repaired.
Lucia: 我修电脑干过最大的工程
Lucia: The biggest project I've done on a computer.
Lucia: 就是给自己加装内存条
Lucia: Was adding a memory stick for myself.
Lucia: 剩下我啥都不敢干
Lucia: I don't dare to do anything else.
Lucia: 因为我要是拆了我就装不回去了
Lucia: Because if I take it apart, I can't put it back together.
Jake: 当时为了换了几个键盘键
Jake: At that time, I replaced a few keyboard keys.
Alice:哈哈哈
Jake: 然后把整个麦克给拆了
Jake: Then I took apart the whole mic.
Lucia: 但是您把它拆了还得组装成台式机
Lucia: But you took it apart and still assembled it into a desktop.
Lucia: 这我真没想到
Lucia: I really didn't expect that.
Lucia: 怎么凭空还多了一些零件呢
Lucia: How did it end up with extra parts?
Jake: 没有就是屏幕散开
Jake: No, the screen just came apart.
Lucia: 就是装回去发现零件多了
Lucia: So when putting it back together, you found extra parts.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:香椿饼是你点的吗
Alice: Did you order the Toona sinensis pancake?
Alice:不是不是吗
Alice: No, didn't you?
Shure:  不是
Shure: No.
Jake: 呃算是呃
Jake: Uh, sort of, uh...
Jake: 百度文信一年都没开
Jake: Baidu Wenxin has been closed for a year.
Alice:哦
Jake: 对只能问百度
Jake: Yeah, you can only ask Baidu.
Shure:  这谷雨要吃啥
Shure: What should we eat for Grain Rain?
Jake: 对他没说饺子
Jake: Yeah, it didn't mention dumplings.
Jake: 但是我们还是点
Jake: But we still ordered them.
Shure:  因为饺子总不会错的
Shure: Because you can never go wrong with dumplings.
Shure:  毕竟好吃不过饺子
Shure: After all, nothing beats dumplings.
Alice:我还以为香椿饼是专门点的
Alice: I thought the Chinese toon pancakes were specially ordered.
Jake: 是是专门点的就是
Jake: Yes, they were specially ordered.
Shure:  为了今天这个节气
Shure: For today's solar term.
Jake: 对问了百度说今儿应该吃点啥
Jake: Yeah, asked Baidu what we should eat today.
Jake: 今天还有叫逛古语还是走
Jake: 古语什么呀
Jake: 走古语
Alice:走谷雨啊
Alice: Strolling Grain Rain.
Alice:出去踏青
Alice: Going out to enjoy the spring.
Tasha: 那我要拿那个
Tasha: Then I'll take that.
Katrina:  那我们去撸狗吧
Katrina: Let's go pet some dogs.
Jake: 对对对对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake: 是啥呀
Jake: What's that?
Shure:  然后唱着采蘑菇的小姑娘哈哈
Shure: And then singing "The Little Mushroom Girl" haha.
Lucia: 我特别喜欢这个颜色哦
Lucia: I really like this color, oh.
Lucia: 感觉很好看
Lucia: It looks really nice.
Jake: 我要把它给先拿出来
Jake: I'm going to take it out first.
Tasha: 这写的什么乱七八糟的
Tasha: What is this messy writing?
Lucia: 希拉维
Lucia: C'est la vie.
Tasha: 是吗这什么语
Tasha: Really? What language is this?
Lucia: 法语哦
Lucia: It's French, oh.
Tasha: 对不起
Tasha: Sorry.
Lucia: 但这个c这是不是写错了
Lucia: But this "c", isn't it written wrong?
Lucia: 应该是CES
Lucia: It should be "CES."
Shure:  可能看到你伤心了吧
Shure: Maybe it saw you were sad.
Katrina:  我没伤心白天跟晚上是两个人
Katrina: I'm not sad, I'm a different person day and night.
Lucia: 希拉维就是指好像这就是生活
Lucia: "C'est la vie" means "it seems like this is life."
Lucia: no是我们
Lucia: No, it's us.
Lucia: 我们的组合
Lucia: Our group.
Lucia: 如果只有一个日的话
Lucia: If there's only one "日," it means "day" or "today."
Lucia: 就是就是白天或者今天的意思
Lucia: It means "day" or "today."
Alice:法语是表音的文字吗
Alice: Is French a phonetic language?
Lucia: 是啊
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 呃不是吗
Lucia: Uh, isn't it?
Lucia: 不是你是圆形的
Lucia: No, you're round.
Alice:不不是不是
Alice: No, no, no.
Alice:我不是我
Alice: I'm not, I...
Alice:没我不知道
Alice: No, I don't know.
Lucia: 应该是吧
Lucia: Maybe.
Lucia: 像他们这些拉丁语系的
Lucia: Like those Latin-based languages.
Lucia: 应该都是表音的
Lucia: They should all be phonetic.
Jake: 应该都就中文
Jake: They should all be in Chinese.
Jake: 还有谁
Jake: Who else?
Lucia: 东亚地区就这些语言
Lucia: East Asian languages are like that.
Tasha: 另一个那个呢
Tasha: What about the other one?
Tasha: 螺丝呢
Tasha: What about the screws?
Jake: 没了在这呢听见一抹的小日本歌
Jake: No more, here you hear a little Japanese song.
Tasha: 这人也太抠了
Tasha: This person is so stingy.
Tasha: 就发4螺丝
Tasha: Only four screws.
Jake: 给我粘上
Jake: Stick it on for me.
Jake: 我们有很多双双面胶
Jake: We have a lot of double-sided tape.
Jake: 摄像头的双面胶
Jake: Double-sided tape for the camera.
Lucia: 哇真猛啊
Lucia: Wow, so intense.
Lucia: 你看过罗翔的那个刑法视频
Lucia: Have you seen Luo Xiang's criminal law videos?
Lucia: 警察局局长从旁边过
Lucia: The police chief walks by.
Lucia: 说好猛啊
Lucia: Says it's awesome.
Tasha: 是这个哦
Tasha: Is it this one?
Lucia: 我法语基本上是看剧学的
Lucia: I mostly learned French from watching shows.
Lucia: 所以就是一旦不是台词我看不懂
Lucia: So if it's not a script, I don't understand.
Jake: 要不翻译一下就是
Jake: How about translating it then?
Lucia: 但谷歌翻译在国内用不上
Lucia: But Google Translate doesn't work in China.
Lucia: 我现在有
Jake: 你现在有了
Jake: You have it now?
Jake: 现在不是墙内人了
Jake: You're not behind the firewall anymore.
Jake: 就在这个墙外墙外墙内不是一个体系
Jake: Inside the wall and outside the wall are different systems.
Lucia: 是不是不太对啊
Lucia: Is this right?
Lucia: 100%阿拉提卡咖啡
Lucia: 100% Arabica coffee.
Tasha: 哪里有咖啡
Tasha: Where's the coffee?
Tasha: 我是说盒子上应该印
Tasha: I mean, it should be printed on the box.
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's okay.
Lucia: 我们可以假装
Lucia: We can pretend.
Jake: 咖啡豆是吧
Jake: Coffee beans, right?
Jake: 我知道这个是英语
Jake: I know this is in English.
Jake: 纯英语这个是什么
Jake: This is pure English.
Jake: 这是哪
Jake: Where is this?
Jake: 国语西语
Jake: Mandarin or Spanish?
Lucia: 不是吧我不知道
Lucia: No way, I don't know.
Tasha: 你说这盒子里能放什么好吃的呢
Tasha: What do you think we can put in this box that's tasty?
Tasha: 这不是开玩笑嘛
Tasha: Isn't this a joke?
Jake: 这个还得晒晒对吧
Jake: This still needs to be dried, right?
Jake: 吹一吹吧
Jake: Let's blow it a bit.
Tasha: 我就把这两盒子拿走
Tasha: I'll just take these two boxes away.
Tasha: 这样子放还比较好放
Tasha: It's easier to place them this way.
Jake: 那我刚刚干嘛了
Jake: So what did I just do?
Jake: 也行吧
Jake: Well, that works too.
Tasha: 这个可以单独的
Tasha: This can be separate.
Tasha: 这样子啊
Tasha: Like this.
Jake: 对对对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Jake: 看来我们东西有很多啊
Jake: Looks like we have a lot of stuff.
Jake: 很多很多
Jake: A lot, a lot.
Alice:这个适合放口红
Alice: This is good for storing lipsticks.
Alice:还带分装格
Alice: It even has compartments.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 这个放进去可以放那个什么放什么
Lucia: This can be used to store, uh, what can it store?
Alice:哎呀这怎么脏脏的
Alice: Oh no, why is this dirty?
Lucia: 耳环耳钉这种小首饰
Lucia: Earrings, studs, small jewelry like that.
Tasha: 好好太好了
Tasha: Great, wonderful.
Lucia: 特别棒首饰盒放桌子上还不占地方
Lucia: It's perfect, a jewelry box on the table doesn't take up much space.
Tasha: 扇一扇
Tasha: Fan it a bit.
Lucia: 我们已经给他想好
Lucia: We've already thought it out for him.
Lucia: 给他想好就是他以后的归宿了
Lucia: We've thought out his future home for him.
Tasha: 这个呢装可爱
Tasha: This one is for being cute.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake: 这怎么装可爱
Jake: How is this cute?
Jake: 这什么玩意
Jake: What is this thing?
Lucia: 他比较可爱
Lucia: It's quite cute.
Jake: 小房子是吧
Jake: A little house, right?
Alice:像那种爆钟的那个壳啊
Alice: Like the cover of a cuckoo clock.
Lucia: 对是的给里面放个放个圆
Lucia: Yes, exactly, you can put a round one inside.
Alice:鸟哈哈哈
Alice: A bird, hahaha.
Lucia: 那个啥墙时钟
Lucia: A wall clock.
Lucia: 然后在上面再放一个小鸟
Lucia: Then put a little bird on top.
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Lucia: 好这个的日后归宿也想好了
Lucia: Okay, we've also thought about the future home for this one.
Lucia: 那俩盘不用给他想什么
Lucia: Those two dishes, no need to think too much about them.
Lucia: 因为都挺都很常见很好用
Lucia: Because they are quite common and very useful.
Alice:这个是不是也能
Alice: Can this also...
Alice:可以养小蜘蛛
Alice: ...be used to raise small spiders?
Alice:一人一个隔间
Alice: Each person gets a compartment.
Lucia: 太小了
Lucia: It's too small.
Lucia: 这个可以养
Lucia: This one can be used.
Lucia: 对狼猪会爬出来
Lucia: Wolves or pigs might climb out.
Alice:我想养蛇
Alice: I want to raise a snake.
Lucia: 我也想养蛇
Lucia: I want to raise a snake too.
Alice:我喜欢两栖动物
Alice: I like amphibians.
Lucia: 对我也想养蛇
Lucia: Yeah, I want to raise a snake too.
Lucia: 但是我之前我还有一个学长
Lucia: But I used to have a senior...
Tasha: 他在养那个什么守宫守宫啊蜥蜴守宫啊
Tasha: He was raising geckos, geckos and lizards.
Alice:手工啊手工啊
Alice: Handmade geckos, handmade geckos.
Tasha: 然后每天他的手上就爬着一条蛇
Tasha: And every day, there was a snake crawling on his hand.
Alice:就这样爬蛇
Alice: Just like that, with a snake crawling.
Tasha: 然后肩上还趴着一条
Tasha: And another one lying on his shoulder.
Tasha: 有点吓人
Tasha: It's a bit scary.
Lucia: 我也想养蛇
Lucia: I also want to raise a snake.
Jake: 狼珠多大呀
Jake: How big is the wolf pearl?
Lucia: 就看你买的多大
Lucia: It depends on how big you buy it.
Alice:这么大吧
Alice: About this big?
Lucia: 也可以你也可以从这么小开始养
Lucia: You can start from this small.
Lucia: 你也可以直接买一个拳头大的
Lucia: Or you can directly buy one the size of a fist.
Lucia: 对他会蜕皮然后慢慢变得很大
Lucia: It'll shed its skin and slowly get bigger.
Jake: 它最大能到哪
Jake: How big can it get?
Alice:也超不过大巴掌吧
Alice: Probably no bigger than a large palm, right?
Lucia: 最大一般可能超不过大巴掌这么大吧
Lucia: Usually, it probably won't get bigger than a large palm.
Lucia: 我感觉
Lucia: I think.
Lucia: 因为直接买拳头那么大的
Lucia: Because if you buy one the size of a fist...
Lucia: 因为从这么小开始养
Lucia: ...if you start raising it from this small...
Lucia: 很容易中间把它养死
Lucia: ...it's easy for it to die in the middle.
Jake: 他营养不够高血
Jake: It doesn't get enough nutrition, blood pressure drops?
Lucia: 呃不知道为啥就是
Lucia: Uh, I don't know why, just...
Alice:掉血
Alice: Blood drops.
Jake: 好吧不知道要养几年
Jake: Okay, I wonder how many years it takes to raise it.
Jake: 这个他能活多久
Jake: How long can it live?
Lucia: 能活多久
Lucia: How long can it live?
Lucia: 我也不知道
Lucia: I don't know either.
Lucia: 我经常把
Lucia: I often...
Alice:这是干嘛的
Alice: What's this for?
Jake: 真不知道
Jake: I really don't know.
Lucia: 能活能活多久啊
Lucia: How long can it live?
Lucia: 两三年应该不清楚
Lucia: Two or three years, I think. Not sure.
Alice:想养蛇
Lucia: 我也想养蛇
Lucia: 但是蛇要吃老鼠崽子
Lucia: But snakes need to eat baby mice.
Alice:虫虫
Alice: Bugs.
Lucia: 对然后那个东西要放冰箱冷藏
Lucia: Yeah, and you have to keep that stuff in the fridge.
Lucia: 我不是很能接受
Lucia: I can't really handle that.
Lucia: 他跟我冰箱
Lucia: Sharing my fridge.
Lucia: 他跟我共用一个冰箱放吃的
Lucia: Sharing the same fridge where I keep my food.
Alice:你可以专门给他买一个冰箱
Alice: You could buy a separate fridge for it.
Jake: 买什么老鼠崽子
Jake: What? Buying baby mice?
Lucia: 舍不得哈哈哈
Lucia: I can't afford it, haha.
Lucia: 太贵了比蛇都贵
Lucia: It's too expensive, more than the snake.
Jake: 老鼠崽子是什么
Jake: What are baby mice?
Lucia: 就老鼠崽子
Lucia: Just baby mice.
Lucia: 那刚出生的老鼠崽子
Lucia: Newborn baby mice.
Jake: 哦然后为什么冻起来
Jake: Oh, and why freeze them?
Lucia: 因为要给蛇吃
Lucia: Because they're for the snake to eat.
Lucia: 就是你不能让它吃的毒死了吧
Lucia: You can't let it eat something that's poisoned, right?
Alice:变质了
Alice: Spoiled.
Jake: 他他是活的吗
Jake: Are they alive?
Lucia: 不是就是应该是新鲜的死老鼠
Lucia: No, they should be fresh, dead mice.
Jake: 为什么能不能
Jake: Why not...
Jake: 能不能养点活的
Jake: Why not keep live ones?
Lucia: 养活老鼠
Lucia: Keeping live mice?
Tasha: 就在大城市开始捕鼠
Tasha: Start catching mice in the big city.
Tasha: 然后卖
Jake: 刚死的活老鼠
Jake: Freshly dead, live mice.
Lucia: 他一般就是
Lucia: They usually...
Lucia: 就是那种爬虫店就会有卖
Lucia: Pet shops usually sell them.
Lucia: 各种各样吃的
Lucia: Various kinds of food.
Lucia: 狼蛛吃的也很那个啥
Lucia: Tarantulas eat that stuff too.
Lucia: 他吃不过那个有的鸟也吃
Lucia: They eat, and some birds eat too.
Lucia: 就那种小虫子
Lucia: Those little bugs.
Lucia: 所以那个还比较好搞
Lucia: So that's easier to manage.
Lucia: 面包虫
Lucia: Mealworms.
Lucia: 就是很多鸟也吃那个
Lucia: Lots of birds eat those too.
Jake: 我以为吃很多鸟
Jake: I thought it ate a lot of birds.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake: 拳头这么大应该也能吃一只
Jake: If it's as big as a fist, it should be able to eat one.
Alice:蜜袋雾也挺好挺可爱的
Alice: Sugar gliders are pretty nice and cute.
Alice:但是他吃的那个东西我实在是受不了
Alice: But the stuff it eats, I really can't stand it.
Alice:我我那个
Alice: I... that...
Alice:大的那个
Alice: The big one...
Alice:大蚕蛹不是大蚕蛹
Alice: The big silkworm pupa, not the big silkworm pupa.
Alice:就是那种
Alice: It's just that...
Alice:说啥呢哦
Alice: What am I saying...
Lucia: 哦是那种
Lucia: Oh, that kind...
Lucia: 就是就是那个炒的那个是吧
Lucia: It's that stir-fried one, right?
Lucia: 就是
Lucia: Yes...
Lucia: 人好像也吃
Lucia: People seem to eat it too.
Alice:就长得像蚕蛹的那个东西
Alice: The one that looks like a silkworm pupa.
Alice:你还得给它撕开
Alice: You have to tear it open.
Jake: 嗯他吃
Jake: Hmm, it eats...
Jake: 中文吗
Jake: Chinese, right?
Alice:对
Jake: 怎么写
Jake: How do you write it?
Alice:蜂蜜的蜜袋鼠的袋雾
Alice: Honey, sugar glider.
Alice:就是那个
Alice: It's that...
Alice:一个鼠一个无
Alice: A mouse, a nothing.
Alice:它会飞也不是会飞
Alice: It can fly, or rather glide.
Lucia: 就是它会滑翔
Lucia: It glides.
Alice:对会滑翔
Alice: Yes, it glides.
Alice:不是一种鸟
Alice: It's not a bird.
Lucia: 它是哺乳动物吧
Lucia: It's a mammal, right?
Alice:是一种
Alice: It's a type of...
Alice:老鼠吧应该是
Alice: Mouse, I think.
Alice:然后它的这个
Alice: And its...
Alice:这个跟它的腿中间有那个翼
Alice: Between its legs, there's a wing.
Alice:然后就是可以从高处把它扔下来
Alice: So you can throw it from a height.
Alice:它就像一个滑翔的效果
Alice: It glides down.
Alice:对然后你就可以用比如说它从那里
Alice: And you can use, for example, from there...
Jake: 蝙蝠的亲戚
Jake: A relative of the bat.
Alice:嗯可以这么理解
Alice: Yeah, you could say that.
Alice:然后
Alice: And...
Alice:我觉得近亲吧
Alice: I think it's a close relative.
Alice:他的表哥表弟
Alice: Like cousins.
Jake: 那他最像的
Jake: What animal does he resemble the most?
Jake: 我一般常见的动物是
Jake: The most common animal I usually see is...
Alice:老鼠夹蝙蝠
Alice: A mouse or a bat.
Jake: 行好好好
Jake: Alright, alright, alright.
Alice:然后比如说从那里飞过来
Alice: And then, for example, if it flies over from there...
Alice:哈哈哈从那里飞过来
Alice: Haha, if it flies over from there...
Alice:然后你就接着它
Alice: And you catch it...
Alice:就它这种就特别粘人
Alice: It's really clingy like that.
Alice:如果你接不住它它不会摔死
Alice: If you don't catch it, it won't die from the fall.
Alice:但是它会被气死
Alice: But it will die from anger.
Alice:就是你为什么接不住我呢
Alice: Like, "Why didn't you catch me?"
Alice:它真的会
Alice: It really will.
Alice:它会气死
Alice: It will die from anger.
Jake: 生气会干嘛就不吃饭
Jake: What happens when it's angry? It won't eat?
Alice:嗯不知道还没养过
Alice: Hmm, I don't know. I haven't raised one.
Alice:反正会被会把自己气死啊
Alice: Anyway, it will die from anger.
Jake: 就是不吃饭估计
Jake: Probably won't eat.
Lucia: 我好想养
Lucia: I really want to raise one.
Lucia: 我喜欢这种比较粘人的动物
Lucia: I like clingy animals like that.
Alice:暹罗猫吗
Alice: Like a Siamese cat?
Alice:暹罗猫像狗一样的
Alice: Siamese cats are like dogs.
Jake: 它认识你
Jake: It recognizes you.
Alice:猫中只狗
Alice: A dog among cats.
Jake: 会认识它认人
Jake: It recognizes people.
Alice:对它很粘人的
Alice: Yeah, they're very clingy.
Jake: 蜘蛛应该没这样吧
Jake: Spiders aren't like that, right?
Lucia: 总共那么大一点
Lucia: They're only that big.
Lucia: 你指望他多大呢
Lucia: How big do you expect them to be?
Lucia: 蛇也不怎么认了
Lucia: Snakes don't really recognize people either.
Lucia: 蛇咬人也很小
Lucia: Snakes bite, but their bites are small.
Alice:就很粘人
Alice: They're very clingy.
Alice:我就喜欢这种粘人小动物
Alice: I just love clingy small animals.
Alice:就小狗
Alice: Like puppies.
Lucia: 但是但是
Lucia: But, but...
Lucia: 我爸妈不喜欢
Lucia: My parents don't like them.
Lucia: 把家里弄得很乱
Lucia: They make the house messy.
Lucia: 所以我就不能养这种什么猫啊狗啊
Lucia: So I can't have cats or dogs.
Lucia: 这个散了
Lucia: That's settled.
Lucia: 虽然我很想养
Lucia: Even though I really want to.
Katrina:  嗯我也没想到这么轻松
Katrina: Hmm, I didn't expect it to be this easy.
Katrina:  每天早上还是10点半起床
Katrina: Every day I still get up at 10:30 AM.
Lucia: 嗯大吗
Lucia: Is it big?
Alice:不大就一个手
Alice: Not really, just one hand.
Alice:他就一个手就能拖着他
Alice: He can hold it with just one hand.
Lucia: 哦哎那还可以
Lucia: Oh, then that's alright.
Alice:你们在脑电波交流吗
Alice: Are you guys communicating telepathically?
Jake: 没有我看他这个灯关了
Jake: No, I saw his light was off.
Lucia: 啊我灯还亮着吗
Alice:我的也亮着
Alice: Mine is still on too.
Jake: 但他其实是这个头发挡住了
Jake: But actually, his hair was just blocking it.
Jake: 所以我刚刚让他撩一下
Jake: So I just asked him to move it.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha
Lucia: 你应该这样
Lucia: You should do it like this.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 就那天那个舞蹈里的动手
Lucia: Like that move in the dance the other day.
Alice:啦啦啦
Alice: Lalala
Alice:所以昨天那个为什么
Alice: So why was that yesterday?
Alice:那个什么161为什么能代表3月21啊
Alice: Why could 161 represent March 21?
Lucia: 不知道可能是GPTS在胡说
Lucia: No idea, maybe GPTS was just talking nonsense.
Tasha: 是不是没发昨天的功工资
Tasha: Didn't we miss yesterday's payroll?
Lucia: 好像是
Lucia: Seems like it.
Alice:所以为什么为什么什么321
Alice: So why, why 321?
Lucia: 他是睡着了
Lucia: He fell asleep.
Alice:161是吧 161为什么能代表3月21呢
Alice: 161, right? How could 161 represent March 21?
Lucia: 不知道啊
Lucia: No idea.
Alice:要不要问一下
Alice: Should we ask?
Lucia: 我觉得GBT在胡说
Lucia: I think GPT was talking nonsense.
Lucia: 因为前一天的时候这个
Lucia: Because the day before, it also split into two, right?
Lucia: 他不是也拆成两个吗
Lucia: And often GPT does that.
Lucia: 然后经常也是的GPT
Lucia: It's usually GPT.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Jake: 里面有一个答案是说132
Jake: One answer said it's 132.
Lucia: 是一个回文数
Lucia: It's a palindrome.
Lucia: 但132明显不是
Lucia: But 132 clearly isn't.
Lucia: 回文数就是正着和倒着一样的
Lucia: A palindrome reads the same forwards and backwards.
Lucia: 就跟回文是一个意思
Lucia: Like a palindrome.
Lucia: 132怎么能是回纹数
Lucia: How can 132 be a palindrome?
Lucia: 我在群里问我说为什么132是回文数
Lucia: I asked in the group why 132 is a palindrome.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 然后他说不知道所以没有采纳
Lucia: And then he said he didn't know, so it wasn't accepted.
Alice:并且那个植树节植植树节
Alice: And that Arbor Day, Arbor Day...
Alice:我还一开始我以为他弄错了
Alice: At first, I thought he got it wrong.
Alice:他不是3月哎
Alice: Isn't it in March?
Lucia: 是3月3月
Lucia: It's in March, March.
Lucia: 3月十几号
Lucia: Around mid-March.
Alice:我我就记得我们不是312植树节吗
Alice: I just remember ours is on March 12th, right?
Lucia: 是吗我不知道但确实
Lucia: Is it? I don't know, but indeed...
Alice:我是我记错了吗
Alice: Am I remembering it wrong?
Alice:但是那个日子
Alice: But that date...
Alice:感觉就是跟我的印象好像不太对
Alice: It just doesn't match my memory.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Alice:然后我还去网上查了一下
Alice: So I checked it online.
Alice:原来每个国家的植树节都不是一样的
Alice: Turns out Arbor Day is different in every country.
Lucia: 原来是这样
Lucia: Oh, I see.
Alice:这不是一个
Alice: It's not a...
Lucia: 它不是个国际统一的节日
Lucia: It's not an internationally unified holiday.
Alice:对对对
Alice: Right, right.
Alice:哎呦啊
Alice: Oh dear.
Jake: 多少克
Jake: How many grams?
Lucia: 我的订单在京东
Lucia: My order is at JD.com.
Lucia: 北京天河散货分拣中心
Lucia: Beijing Tianhe Sorting Center.
Lucia: 分拣完成
Lucia: Sorting completed.
Lucia: 我觉得今天应该能到一个
Lucia: I think it should arrive today.
Katrina:  学是学会了已经
Katrina: You've already learned it.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 别到时候我在淘宝上买那些小装饰
Lucia: Just don't let me end up buying those little decorations on Taobao...
Lucia: 都没到然后那就会导致就是就是
Lucia: and they don't arrive, then it would mean...
Lucia: 我所有到的东西都是白色的
Lucia: everything I get is white.
Lucia: 没有一个是白色
Lucia: None of it is white.
Alice:白色是鼠水还是鸡呢
Alice: Is white for water or chicken?
Alice:水吧黑白
Alice: Water, right? Black and white.
Lucia: 就是以蓝白为主色调的
Lucia: Mostly blue and white tones.
Lucia:    所以我挑的都是蓝白的东西
Lucia: So everything I picked is blue and white.
Alice:蓝白应该都属水吧好像
Alice: Blue and white should be for water, I think.
Alice:好的谢谢您
Alice: Okay, thank you.
Alice:啊阿姨
Alice: Ah, auntie.
Alice:那个底下那个黑色袋子里面是
Alice: That black bag at the bottom...
Alice:是那个玻璃碎渣
Alice: has glass shards in it.
Alice:就就这个黑色袋子
Alice: This black bag here.
Alice:这个这个我放出来
Alice: This one, let me take it out.
Alice:对里面是玻璃渣
Alice: Yeah, it's filled with glass shards.
Alice:你要小心一下
Alice: Be careful.
Lucia: 小心一点
Lucia: Watch out.
其他人：我把这个垃圾袋直接换了
Others: I'll just replace this trash bag.
其他人：一会下来时候拿个大垃圾袋啊
Others: When you come down, bring a big trash bag.
Alice:这里面是玻璃渣
Alice: There are glass shards inside.
Alice:你小心点
Alice: Be careful.
其他人：我装这个袋子
Others: I'll pack this bag.
其他人：这个袋子厚一点
Others: This bag is a bit thicker.
Alice:好好好给你扯
Alice: Okay, I'll help you with it.
其他人：没事没事你接吧接吧
Others: It's fine, you just take it.
Alice:好谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Alice:没关系
Alice: It's alright.
Lucia: 哎呦不好意思
Alice:你好纤细
Alice: You're so delicate.
Alice:嗯哈哈
Alice: Haha, yeah.
Alice:好纤细
Alice: So delicate.
Alice:对我一只手就能这样搂着你了
Alice: I can hold you with one hand.
Lucia: 夏天穿的少
Lucia: It's because we wear less in summer.
Alice:你抱我是不是duang duang的
Alice: Do you feel a bounce when you hug me?
Lucia: 没有呀哈哈哈
Lucia: No, haha.
Lucia: 我觉得拥抱是一件很开心的事情
Lucia: I think hugging is a happy thing.
Alice:拥抱会分泌那什么
Alice: Hugging releases... something.
Alice:忘了反正就四种激素之一
Alice: I forgot, one of the four hormones.
Alice:催产素吧
Alice: Oxytocin, maybe.
Lucia: 嗯多抱一会咦
Lucia: Yeah, hug longer, yikes.
Alice:好像是催产素
Alice: I think it's oxytocin.
Alice:如果没记错的话
Alice: If I remember correctly.
Lucia: 哎他们刚刚有找到剪刀吗
Lucia: Did they find the scissors?
Lucia: 我就可以把这个箱子给他拆了吗
Lucia: So I can unpack this box now?
Lucia: 呃有的不要了
Lucia: Some of it can be discarded.
Lucia: 有的还要
Lucia: Some of it still needed.
Katrina:  把它剪下来然后把它平开
Katrina: Cut it down and lay it flat.
Katrina:  然后这样放出去就行
Katrina: Then just put it out like this.
Lucia: 雨轩有找到剪刀吗
Lucia: Did Yuxuan find the scissors?
Katrina:  哎找到了
Katrina: Yep, found it.
Katrina:  剪刀是那个冰箱里的
Katrina: It's in the fridge.
Alice:还有另一
Alice: There's another...
Katrina:  但这个好拆
Katrina: But this one's easy to open.
Katrina:  快递吗
Katrina: Is it a delivery?
Alice:来吧我来给你拆吧
Alice: Come on, let me open it for you.
Lucia: 吧柔软一点的
Lucia: Make it a bit softer.
Alice:柔软一点
Alice: Softer.
Alice:我来给你拆
Alice: I'll open it for you.
Alice:你说你要哪个
Alice: Which one do you want?
Lucia: 没事拆快递
Lucia: It's fine, just unpacking the delivery.
Lucia: 没事没事拆快递其实我用我用这个东西拆也可以
Lucia: It's fine, really. I can use this to open it too.
Lucia: 我是在想
Lucia: I was thinking...
Lucia: 如果我们要做一个纸箱鼓的话
Lucia: If we want to make a cardboard drum...
Lucia: 就需要用剪刀把这个剪掉
Lucia: ...we'll need scissors to cut this.
Alice:这个哦那我们肯定有剪子的那个剪子
Alice: Oh, that. We definitely have scissors.
Lucia: 那个就要用那个
Lucia: We need those.
Lucia: 就是全是铁的那种剪刀
Lucia: The all-metal kind.
Alice:我给你找找
Alice: I'll go find them for you.
Lucia: 那个我怕就是给他别用
Lucia: I'm worried they'll be too strong and break it.
Lucia: 用劲太大剪劈了
Lucia: If we use too much force.
Katrina:  嗯哎
Katrina: Hmm, yeah.
Lucia: 现在戴着眼镜我可以拆这个快递了吧
Lucia: Now that I'm wearing glasses, can I open this package?
Lucia: 拆了管他可以反正没什么事
Lucia: I'll just open it, it's no big deal.
Alice:我找到了
Alice: I found them.
Lucia: 那个是用来压花的吗
Lucia: Are those for pressing flowers?
Shure:  慢慢的一圈一圈
Shure: Slowly, round and round.
Lucia: 可以可以有个剪刀
Lucia: Okay, we have scissors.
Lucia: 然后我们好像没有铅笔
Lucia: But we seem to be missing a pencil.
Lucia: 但实在不行白板笔也行
Lucia: If we really need one, a whiteboard marker will do.
Katrina:  我有那个黑纸
Katrina: I have some black paper.
Lucia: 呃那个碳碳素笔那种吗
Lucia: Uh, like a carbon pen?
Katrina:  就是普通的墨墨水笔啊
Katrina: Just a regular ink pen.
Lucia: 可以也可以你要
Lucia: That works too.
Katrina:  你要干什么就是
Katrina: What do you need it for?
Lucia: 就是在纸板上画一下啊
Lucia: Just to draw on the cardboard.
Lucia: 我要那个什么
Lucia: I need it for...
Katrina:  我给你找找去
Katrina: I'll go find it for you.
Lucia: 没事没事不着急你可以先弄你的这个
Lucia: No rush, it's fine. You can work on your stuff first.
Katrina:  你有想好要做什么样的小狗吗
Katrina: Have you decided what kind of puppy you want to make?
Lucia: 没想好因为
Lucia: Not yet, because...
Lucia: 因为我不知道咱们是想要一个
Lucia: ...because I don't know if we want a...
Lucia: 就是粗狗一点的还是
Lucia: ...a chunky puppy or...
Alice:是一人一支吗
Alice: Is it one each?
Lucia: 可以一起做
Lucia: We can do it together.
Lucia: 反正我们好多人
Lucia: Anyway, we've got a lot of people.
Katrina:  就是这个活动啥的就是感觉压花什么都是随便你
Katrina: This event, you know, you can press flowers or whatever you want.
Katrina:  想玩就玩
Katrina: Play if you want to play.
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Alice:好好好
Katrina:  我当时以为就是必须每个人想一个
Katrina: At first, I thought everyone had to come up with something.
Katrina:  游戏就是每个人都要参与的
Katrina: The game, like, everyone had to participate.
Lucia: 对我也是
Lucia: Me too.
Alice:那我就要做一只发疯的小狗
Alice: Then I'll be a crazy little dog.
Katrina:  后来发现特别佛系
Katrina: Later, I found out it's super chill.
Lucia: 就是就是其实那个狗很好做
Lucia: Actually, making that dog is easy.
Lucia: 如果大家只是想潦草一点做的话
Lucia: If you just want to make it casually.
Lucia: 就拿一个箱子
Lucia: Just grab a box.
Lucia: 但是长宽比例要合适一点
Lucia: But make sure the proportions are right.
Lucia: 然后简单剪一下
Lucia: Then just cut it simply.
Lucia: 对就行了
Lucia: Yeah, that's it.
Lucia: 简单剪一下然后给他
Lucia: Just cut it a bit, then...
Lucia: 就你再拿另外一个那种
Lucia: Then take another piece of paper.
Lucia: 就是把那个纸然后画一个
Lucia: Draw a dog's head on it.
Lucia: 小狗脑袋把它粘上
Lucia: Stick it on.
Alice:嗯我看过别人做
Alice: Yeah, I've seen others do it.
Lucia: 我看还有很多就是那种的
Lucia: I've seen a lot of those.
Alice:我觉得比例失调也没关系啊
Alice: I think it's okay if the proportions are off.
Alice:就有那种超级细长的那种细狗
Alice: There are those really long, skinny dogs.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 就是就更加符合潦草小狗的形象
Lucia: It fits the image of a sloppy little dog even more.
Alice:我是不是可以把眼镜先去掉
Alice: Should I take my glasses off first?
Alice:一会我要上厕所
Alice: I need to go to the bathroom later.
Alice:这不能录吧
Alice: This can't be recorded, right?
Alice:这能播吗这不能播
Alice: Can this be broadcast? This can't be broadcast.
Alice:这能录吗
Alice: Can this be recorded?
Alice:这不能录
Alice: This can't be recorded.
Lucia: 你可以先放桌子上
Lucia: You can put it on the table first.
Lucia: 然后出出来了再带
Lucia: Then put them on after you come out.
Lucia: 应该没事了
Lucia: It should be fine.
Alice:好给你多来一个机位OK
Alice: Alright, I'll give you another camera angle, OK?
Lucia: 这个是谁的呀
Lucia: Whose is this?
Katrina:  OK
Katrina: OK.
Lucia: 这个也是昨天到的
Lucia: This one also arrived yesterday.
Lucia: 有谁的快有谁的
Lucia: Whose is it?
Lucia: 京东快递是昨天到的吗
Lucia: Did the JD package arrive yesterday?
Katrina:  没有我没买京东
Katrina: No, I didn't buy anything from JD.
Katrina:  我都是淘宝
Katrina: I always use Taobao.
Katrina:  这什么东西啊
Katrina: What is this thing?
Lucia: 不知道因为这上面没写名字
Lucia: I don't know because there's no name on it.
Katrina:  易碎物品
Katrina: Fragile items.
Lucia: 然后我觉得应该也不是我的
Lucia: And I think it's not mine either.
Lucia: 因为我昨天应该就到了俩
Lucia: Because I received two packages yesterday.
Katrina:  杨杨这个笑脸
Katrina: Look at this smiley face, Yang Yang.
Katrina:  这谁写的
Katrina: Who wrote this?
Katrina:  应该我写的
Katrina: Probably me.
Katrina:  杨靖康
Katrina: Yang Jingkang.
Lucia: 杨笑脸那可能是他自己写的
Lucia: Yang with the smiley face, maybe he wrote it himself.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我写的
Lucia: Haha, I wrote it.
Lucia: 我写的是
Lucia: I wrote it.
Lucia: 是我一直用来收快递的朱先生就是我写的
Lucia: It's Mr. Zhu, the name I always use for receiving packages, I wrote it.
Shure:  刚才退了3个
Shure: Just returned three items.
Lucia: 我微信不是这样的
Lucia: My WeChat isn't like that.
Lucia: 哥朱先生
Lucia: Brother, Mr. Zhu.
Shure:  咱们给他补了个水壶了
Shure: We replaced it with a water bottle for him.
Katrina:  还这种
Katrina: Even this kind.
Katrina:  小花好呀
Katrina: Hi, Xiaohua.
Katrina:  大花就
Katrina: Dahua is just...
Tasha: 打歌服的话我还没有买
Tasha: As for the performance outfits, I haven't bought them yet.
Tasha: 我们要不要看看
Tasha: Should we take a look?
Tasha: 还是
Tasha: Or...
Tasha: 嗯对怎么说呢
Tasha: Hmm, how should I say it...
Tasha: 我看了好多
Tasha: I looked at many of them.
Tasha: 我在想每个人应该不太一样才行
Tasha: I think each one should be a bit different.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
Alice:要不要就就那种粉黑色的
Alice: How about those pink and black ones?
Alice:然后你看
Alice: And then look at this.
Lucia: 男生跳舞跟我们一样的
Lucia: The boys dancing the same as us.
Tasha: 有你看这种的
Tasha: Look at these kinds.
Tasha: 这种的这个粉黑的
Tasha: This pink and black one.
Katrina:  这好好看
Katrina: This one looks great.
Tasha: 粉黑的这个对吧
Tasha: The pink and black one, right?
Tasha: 然后还有这个也可以来个粉黑的
Tasha: And then this one can also be pink and black.
Tasha: 然后这个也可以粉黑的
Tasha: And this one can also be pink and black.
Katrina:  真给爆了
Katrina: This is really awesome.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Tasha: 我现在就是觉得一套还有这套
Tasha: Right now I feel like there's this set and that set.
Tasha: 他他也是粉粉黑的那种
Tasha: He's also kind of pink and black.
Katrina:  嗯他给
Katrina: Hmm, he gave...
Katrina:  多少预算
Katrina: ...how much budget?
Tasha: 我尽量
Tasha: I'll try my best.
Tasha: 还可以吧
Tasha: It should be fine.
Tasha: 然后应该有三套了
Tasha: Then there should be three sets.
Tasha: 我在想哇这么重
Tasha: I'm thinking, wow, so heavy.
Tasha: 嗯对我找了好久才找到
Tasha: Yeah, I searched for a long time to find it.
Tasha: 我找了好久
Tasha: I searched for a long time.
Tasha: 就是好好多平台来回找才找着哎
Tasha: I had to go through so many platforms to finally find it.
Katrina:  咱一共是一二三四个女生
Katrina: So, altogether, there are four girls.
Lucia: 嗯你看这边这边还有这个
Lucia: Yeah, look, there's this one and this one.
Tasha: 我们这个也是这个
Tasha: We have this one too.
Tasha: 他可以团队
Tasha: He can team up.
Tasha: 这个这个然后一套两套
Tasha: This one, then one set, two sets...
Tasha: 一套两套
Tasha: One set, two sets...
Tasha: 还有这个
Tasha: And this one.
Tasha: 这个好五套五套六套就可以了
Tasha: Okay, five sets, five sets, six sets will do.
Tasha: 或者
Tasha: Or...
Tasha: 这一套
Tasha: This set.
Katrina:  嗯这一套也好看
Katrina: Hmm, this set looks good too.
Katrina:  你要不直接发群
Katrina: Why don't you just send it to the group?
Katrina:  然后大家挑
Katrina: Then everyone can choose.
Tasha: 就6套吗
Tasha: So, six sets?
Tasha: 一共
Tasha: Altogether.
Lucia: 然后就是我现在就想摸一套200
Lucia: And then, I just want to get one set for 200.
Katrina:  一套200块的话6套1200
Katrina: If one set is 200, then six sets are 1200.
Tasha: 差不多1,000块钱左右
Tasha: About 1000 yuan or so.
Tasha: 他会拨吗
Tasha: Will he approve?
Katrina:  你去问一下杨老板
Katrina: You should ask Jake.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Tasha: 然后如果想要的话还得发顺丰才能够
Tasha: And if we want it, we have to send it via SF Express to get it by Sunday.
Tasha: 周日到啊
Tasha: To arrive by Sunday.
Katrina:  对确实对
Katrina: Yeah, that's right.
Tasha: 就是挑了好久才能找到一个一些
Tasha: It took a long time to find a few.
Katrina:  行你先问他预算吧
Katrina: Okay, you ask him about the budget first.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Tasha: 我们跳舞团团长去问一下
Tasha: Our dance team leader should ask.
Katrina:  我靠我有点害怕
Katrina: Oh gosh, I'm a bit scared.
Tasha: 哈哈我也有点害怕
Tasha: Haha, I'm a bit scared too.
Tasha: 就是感觉有点太高了
Tasha: It just feels a bit too high.
Tasha: 但是但是每套都要很精致好看的话
Tasha: But if every outfit has to be very delicate and pretty...
Tasha:一百多也不贵
Tasha: Over a hundred isn't expensive.
Katrina:  那就在群里问吧
Katrina: Then just ask in the group.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  说杨老板那个衣服给多少钱报销
Katrina: Ask Jake how much he will reimburse for those clothes.
Katrina:  哦那楼上没有牙膏了
Katrina: Oh, there's no toothpaste upstairs.
Katrina:  楼上没有牙膏
Katrina: No toothpaste upstairs.
Katrina:  对没有牙膏
Katrina: Yeah, no toothpaste.
Tasha: 怎么说随时问一下
Katrina: 那就在群里跟他说一下
Katrina:  就是现在找不到他人了
Katrina: We just can't find him now.
Katrina:  然后先在群里问一下
Katrina: So let's ask in the group first.
Tasha: 你问问杨老板
Tasha: Ask Jake.
Tasha: 打歌服六
Tasha: Performance outfit, six...
Tasha: 个人1,000块钱
Tasha: Each person, 1,000 yuan.
Tasha: 钱服装
Tasha: Money for costumes.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Alice:打歌服是吗
Alice: Performance outfit, right?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Alice:这什么小贴纸
Alice: What kind of small stickers are these?
Katrina:  四女两男
Katrina: Four women, two men.
Katrina:  这是
Katrina: This is...
Katrina: 修硕乐队的logo
Katrina: Shure's band logo.
Lucia: 这是送给大家的伴手礼
Lucia: These are the souvenirs for everyone.
Alice:这是鸟身上长了个柳树吗
Alice: Is this a bird with a willow tree growing on it?
Alice:是吗
Alice: Really?
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Lucia: 哇这个好大啊
Lucia: Wow, this is so big.
Lucia: 可比我想象的要
Lucia: It's much bigger than I imagined.
Alice:去接一下水
Alice: Go get some water.
Alice:你这看起来零零碎碎的
Alice: This looks all fragmented.
Alice:不太好拼的样子
Alice: It doesn't seem easy to assemble.
Alice:来我想过一下
Alice: Let me think about it.
Alice:露西啊
Alice: Lucia...
Alice:先挂着
Alice: Just hang it up first.
Alice:水流好小啊
Alice: The water flow is so small.
Alice:多喝水家人多喝水
Alice: Drink more water, everyone, drink more water.
Alice:有益身体健康
Alice: It's good for your health.
Lucia: 也不用都我看一眼
Lucia: You don't all have to look at me.
Alice:如果你看我的电影听
Alice: If you watch my movie, listen...
Alice:我爱的
Alice: I love it.
Alice:阿姨那个没人可以进去嗯
Alice: Auntie, no one can go in there, yeah.
Alice:你这个是你们的设计的LOGO吗
Alice: Is this your designed logo?
Alice:这是鸟上长了个柳树的意思吗
Alice: Does this mean a bird growing a willow tree?
Shure:  不是
Shure: No.
Alice:这不是一个鸟吗
Alice: Isn't this a bird?
Shure:  是鸟对
Shure: It is a bird, yes.
Alice:这是柳树吗
Alice: Is this a willow tree?
Shure:  这大概就是那种比较克苏鲁的感觉
Shure: It's more like a Cthulhu vibe.
Shure:  你知道吧
Shure: You know?
Shure:  不是柳树
Shure: Not a willow tree.
Shure:  是那个内心是一个孩子那种感觉你懂吗
Shure: It's like that feeling of having a childlike heart, you know?
Katrina:  哈哈哈直接把人解释蒙了
Katrina: Haha, you totally confused her with that explanation.
Katrina:  那个打歌服的预算是
Katrina: What's the budget for the stage outfits?
Alice:白鸟白
Alice: White bird white...
Jake: 一般是多少啊
Jake: How much is it usually?
Jake: 我不太懂
Jake: I don't really know.
Katrina:  刚刚那个谁微微看的是一百多一套
Katrina: Earlier, Tasha was looking at ones that were over 100 per set.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Katrina:  100多一套的六套的话那100多 100
Katrina: If it's over 100 per set and we need six sets, that’s over 100...
Katrina:  多那就是1,000
Katrina: So that’s 1,000.
Jake: 就是
Jake: Exactly.
Jake: 六六百 600多
Jake: Like 600 and something.
Jake: 什么样的
Jake: What do they look like?
Lucia: 他说挑的是粉色跟黑色系列
Lucia: They said they chose pink and black series.
Alice:哦对不起阿姨
Alice: Oh, sorry, Auntie.
Katrina:  哎他在这
Katrina: Hey, he's here.
Jake: 来瞅一瞅你们的衣服
Jake: Come take a look at your clothes.
Alice:（歌词）如果你看我的电影听我爱的CD
Alice: (Lyrics) If you watch my movie, listen to my favorite CD...
Alice:我想要拿什么来着
Alice: What was I trying to get again?
Alice:我要干嘛来着
Alice: What was I going to do again?
Alice:不记得了
Alice: I don't remember.
Lucia: 这是啥情况
Lucia: What's going on here?
Alice:我可以看一下这个吗
Alice: Can I take a look at this?
Katrina:  可以这是我觉得眼神不好
Katrina: Sure, I think my eyesight is bad.
Katrina:  土里面长了两个
Katrina: Two things grew in the soil...
Katrina:  还能
Katrina: And they still...
Katrina:  这个然后还有就是
Katrina: So, and also...
Katrina:  那个可以弄在那个亚克力板里面
Katrina: That can be put inside the acrylic board.
Katrina:  应该会挺好看
Katrina: It should look pretty good.
Katrina:  我想要不要压一点
Katrina: Should I press it a bit?
Katrina:  你要压吗
Katrina: Do you want to press it?
Katrina:  现在还有
Katrina: There's still some left.
Katrina:  你可以把你那个盛开的就压一下
Katrina: You can press the one that's already bloomed.
Alice:我的好像
Alice: Mine seems...
Alice:我看
Alice: Let me see...
Katrina:  随便弄两个就行
Katrina: Just do a couple casually.
Katrina:  我这有有几个板
Katrina: I have a few boards here.
Katrina:  皮克皮克
Katrina: Peek-a-boo, peek-a-boo!
Katrina:  其实特简单
Katrina: It's actually super simple.
Katrina:  就是把它一层层叠起来
Katrina: Just stack them layer by layer.
Katrina:  然后铺在上面
Katrina: Then spread them on top.
Katrina:  然后把它绑住就可以
Katrina: And then tie them up, that's it.
Alice:它的原理
Alice: The principle behind it...
Alice:是不是就是让这些容易吸水的材质
Alice: Is it to let these absorbent materials...
Alice:把它的水分吸干
Alice: Absorb all the moisture?
Tasha: 租的不知道
Tasha: I don't know about renting.
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Ah.
Jake: 或者这玩意这玩意
Jake: Or this thing, this thing...
Jake: 哎或者这玩意能二手吗
Jake: Ah, or can this thing be bought second-hand?
Jake: 或者这玩意能干掉吗
Jake: Or can this thing be dried out?
Tasha: 干掉
Tasha: Dried out?
Tasha: 什么意思
Tasha: What do you mean?
Jake: 就是就是省点钱
Jake: Just to save some money.
Tasha: 哈哈超预算了
Tasha: Haha, we've gone over budget.
Alice:那要不统一买50块钱一套的
Alice: How about we all buy sets for 50 bucks each?
Jake: 不是就看你问问他
Jake: No, just ask him.
Jake: 你问问他
Jake: Ask him.
Katrina:  这个可以买便宜点的嘛
Katrina: We can buy cheaper ones, right?
Katrina:  穿一次那种
Katrina: Like the kind you wear once.
Jake: 便宜点或者你看能不能退掉
Jake: Cheaper ones, or see if you can return them.
Jake: 二手还是能不能借租
Jake: Second-hand or see if you can rent.
Alice:或者搜一下附近有没有什么拍照的
Alice: Or search nearby for some photo studios.
Alice:什么写真馆的
Alice: Like portrait studios.
Alice:他们那种礼服可以租吧
Alice: They might have dresses for rent.
Jake: 这种也行
Jake: That works too.
Jake:100块钱我说租他电脑我再拿20块
Jake: I said I'd rent his computer for 100 bucks and take 20 more.
Tasha: 或者这个就全部都买这一款
Tasha: Or we can just buy this one entirely.
Tasha: 这一款才40块钱一套
Tasha: This one only costs 40 bucks a set.
Jake: 就看我们看看有没有别的渠道吧
Jake: Let's see if we have other options.
Jake: 就是除了买
Jake: Other than buying, I mean.
Alice:我看看找啥呀
Alice: Let me see what we can find.
Tasha: 可以可以
Tasha: Sure, sure.
Tasha: 配黑裤子也可以男生
Tasha: Pairing with black pants works for guys too.
Jake:对因为买的话好像没啥退嘛
Jake: Yeah, because if we buy, there's no return, right?
Jake: 你问能不能退
Jake: Ask if we can return it.
Jake: 或者就是或者就是他
Jake: Or just, or just...
Jake: 他这个商家也没有什么租的
Jake: This vendor doesn't offer rentals either.
Katrina:  没办法这个必须要做点手工活
Katrina: No choice, we have to do some handiwork.
Katrina:  我们要环保
Katrina: We need to be eco-friendly.
Jake: 你说我们就要6套吗
Jake: You said we need six sets, right?
Jake: 你这是一家店啊
Jake: This is one store, huh?
Jake: 不同的店
Jake: Different stores.
Katrina:  我知道啊
Katrina: I know.
Katrina:  所以这个还算比较简单
Katrina: So this is relatively easy.
Katrina:  他其实只要把花瓣铺上面
Katrina: He just needs to lay the petals on top.
Katrina:  一定是哪个环节出了问题
Katrina: There must be a problem in some step.
Katrina:  我看一下
Katrina: Let me check.
Katrina:  你压这种大花瓣应该就不会有什么问题
Katrina: If you press these big petals, there shouldn't be any issue.
Alice:为什么我觉得这个屋子比别的要热
Alice: Why do I feel this room is hotter than others?
Alice:是因为电脑多吗
Alice: Is it because there are more computers?
Jake: 我觉得是
Jake: I think so.
Alice:这个灯像一个苹果派
Alice: This light looks like an apple pie.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Alice:还有那个花边边
Alice: And those edges too.
Tasha: 哦还真有租的
Tasha: Oh, there really are rentals.
Tasha: 嗯嗯那只能租这种
Tasha: Yeah, but we can only rent this type.
Jake:多少钱
Jake: How much?
Alice:我看
Alice: Let me see.
Tasha: 45一套那为什么不买一套呢
Tasha: 45 per set, so why not just buy a set?
Tasha: 买一套不在40吗
Tasha: Isn't buying a set 40?
Jake: 确实租一
Jake: Yeah, renting is...
Jake: 这是什么
Jake: What's this?
Jake: 一件40租赁
Jake: 40 for one, for rental.
Alice:是的
Alice: Right.
Jake: 租多久
Jake: For how long?
Tasha: 租多久不知道呀
Tasha: Not sure how long to rent it.
Jake: 那这个是很厉害的服装吗
Jake: Is this a really fancy outfit?
Jake: 这得1,000
Jake: This costs 1,000.
Alice:但是这好像都是女的
Alice: But it seems like these are all for women.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 他这边写真馆租租衣服的也比较多
Tasha: They rent clothes a lot at this photo studio.
Tasha: 40块钱三一天
Tasha: 40 bucks for three days.
Alice:是一般都是按一天一天一天30
Alice: Usually, it's 30 bucks per day.
Jake: 一天30
Jake: 30 bucks a day.
Lucia: 嗯那我要买一套40
Lucia: Hmm, I want to buy a set for 40.
Alice:那就只能买最便宜的那个要花了
Alice: Then you can only get the cheapest one.
Lucia: 嗯嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake: 就是不是那么重
Jake: It's not that heavy.
Katrina:  他的重心
Katrina: Its center of gravity.
Alice:这里可以点歌吗
Alice: Can we request songs here?
Alice:可以我想听蝴蝶
Alice: I want to hear "Butterfly."
Katrina:  蝴蝶我也想听蝴蝶
Katrina: I also want to hear "Butterfly."
Katrina:  再压一层
Katrina: Layer it again.
Alice:对
Alice: Yeah.
Katrina:  那肯定是我还没有决定
Katrina: I'm still not sure.
Katrina:  好陶喆
Katrina: Let's play David Tao.
Jake: 这是什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Jake: 桌子怎么长成这样
Jake: Why does this table look like this?
Katrina:  这是收纳箱哎
Katrina: It's a storage box.
Lucia: 不是他拼起来
Lucia: No, he assembled it.
Katrina:  我到时候买这些装饰房间东西
Katrina: I'll buy these room decorations later.
Katrina:  我就不带回去
Katrina: I won't take them back.
Katrina:  我直接给你寄过来
Katrina: I'll just mail them to you.
Alice:妈呀这是一个不太小的工作量呀
Alice: Wow, that's quite a lot of work.
Alice:我来帮你吧
Alice: Let me help you.
Katrina:  到时候直接放我房间就行
Katrina: Just put them in my room then.
Katrina:  买那种香薰还有地毯还有挂画
Katrina: I'll buy scented candles, carpets, and wall art.
Alice:我来看吧
Alice: Let me see.
Katrina:  还有娃娃
Katrina: And stuffed animals.
Lucia: 就是他带一个抽屉
Lucia: It comes with a drawer.
Lucia: 所以他会边上要
Lucia: So it needs to be on the side.
Alice:每次一想到你就
Alice: Every time I think of you...
Jake: 走吧吃饺子去
Jake: Let's go eat dumplings.
Katrina:  去二楼吃饺子吗
Katrina: Upstairs on the second floor?
Jake: 二楼吃饺子
Jake: Dumplings on the second floor.
Alice:到了吗
Alice: Are we there yet?
Jake: 对冰箱也可以
Jake: Yes, the fridge works too.
Alice:我们吃饭的时候需要录吗
Alice: Do we need to record while we eat?
Jake: 呃吃饭录着吧
Jake: Uh, let's record while eating.
Lucia: 他觉得完全不需要这个空气哈哈
Lucia: He thinks we don't need this air, haha.
Jake: 空心镯子是吧
Jake: A hollow bracelet, right?
Lucia: 就是他是一个
Lucia: Yeah, it's like...
Lucia: 这个上面有没有看到呈现了收纳
Lucia: Did you see the storage on this?
Lucia: 那最后是一个这样的一个小东西
Lucia: And finally, there's this small thing.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 就有点像小床头柜
Lucia: It's kind of like a bedside table.
Alice:让我看看
Alice: Let me see.
Jake: 嗯那这个就合理了起来
Jake: Hmm, that makes sense now.
Alice:我也想看看
Alice: I want to see it too.
Jake: 突然makesense
Jake: Suddenly it makes sense.
Alice:你的拼音好
Alice: Your pinyin is good.
Alice:好等会呢
Alice: Okay, wait a minute.
Tasha: 培养皿买了吗
Tasha: Did you buy the petri dish?
Tasha: 在哪
Tasha: Where is it?
Tasha: 还不种
Tasha: Haven't planted it yet?
Jake: 不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake: 种
Jake: Plant it.
Jake: 呃看他是不是看他到都没到
Jake: Uh, check if it's here or not.
Alice:每次一想到你
Alice: Every time I think of you...
Jake: 还有别的喝吗
Jake: Is there anything else to drink?
Alice:看见一只蝴蝶或飞絮
Alice: I see a butterfly or floating fluff...
Katrina:  这个这有个快递
Katrina: There's a package here.
Katrina:  是那个杨笑脸谁的
Katrina: Whose is it, the one for Yang Xiaolian?
Jake: 笑脸
Jake: Xiaolian?
Katrina:  我给你我直接写的杨靖康
Katrina: I wrote it as Yang Jingkang.
Katrina:  那应该不是我买的
Katrina: It shouldn't be mine.
Katrina:  杨笑脸
Katrina: Yang Xiaolian.
Jake: 杨笑脸interesting
Jake: Yang Xiaolian, interesting.
Katrina:  是你买的吗
Katrina: Did you buy it?
Jake: 我不知道我看一下
Jake: I don't know, let me check.
Jake: 这什么这什么呀
Jake: What's this? What's this?
Lucia: 这什么呀
Lucia: What's this?
Jake: 蝴蝶风铃
Jake: A butterfly wind chime.
Lucia: 我的
Lucia: It's mine.
Katrina:  这是我材料包
Katrina: This is my material pack.
Katrina:  今天又做手工了
Katrina: Doing crafts again today.
Katrina:  昨天化妆今天不想化妆
Katrina: I put on makeup yesterday, don't feel like it today.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina:  这我买的蝴蝶风铃
Katrina: This is the butterfly wind chime I bought.
Alice:啊啊啊
Alice: Ahhh!
Alice:一层一层
Alice: Layer by layer.
Alice:风雨不能前行
Alice: The wind and rain can't move forward.
Katrina:  你在追什么剧啊
Katrina: What show are you watching?
Jake: 这是货币是吧
Jake: This is currency, right?
Jake: 中央银行
Jake: Central Bank.
Katrina:  哈哈哈150个差不多吧
Katrina: Hahaha, about 150 should be enough.
Jake: 可以挺好大银行
Jake: Sure, that's good, big bank.
Alice:（歌词）每次一想到你
Alice: (Lyrics) Every time I think of you.
Alice:（歌词）我会永远爱你
Alice: (Lyrics) I will always love you.
Alice:淘集集嗯
Alice: Taobao, hmm.
Lucia: 哦我明白了这好像也不是那么难搞
Lucia: Oh, I get it, this doesn't seem that hard to handle.
Katrina:  呵呵AI学习中
Katrina: Haha, AI is learning.
Jake: 呵呵挺好
Jake: Haha, pretty good.
Jake: 你这说明书对应的挺好呵呵呵
Jake: Your manual matches well, haha.
Tasha: 通州区演出服装租赁
Tasha: Costume rental in Tongzhou District.
Jake: 这个好甚至我们可以去挑啊
Jake: That's good, we can even go pick it out.
Jake: 如果不远的话
Jake: If it's not far.
Jake: 我们
Jake: We...
Jake: 不远的话下午我们打个车去挑衣服
Jake: If it's not far, we can take a taxi in the afternoon to pick clothes.
Jake: 都可以
Jake: All good.
Tasha: 为什么不能打个车去买衣服哈哈哈
Tasha: Why can't we just take a taxi to buy clothes, hahaha.
Tasha: 因为我只是随便说到
Tasha: Because I was just casually mentioning it.
Jake: 到到时候算算
Jake: We'll count it then.
Jake: 算一算看看这打车费加上这多少钱
Jake: Calculate it, see how much the taxi fare adds up to.
Jake: 打折费应该到不了1,000
Jake: The discount fare shouldn't reach 1,000.
Lucia: 做一个预算控制表
Lucia: Make a budget control sheet.
Lucia: 财务人员的以上工作
Lucia: That's the job of the finance staff.